non
et
d
voilà monsieur bonsoir et bienvenue en
salles de rédaction du 19/20 pour une
heure d'actualité dont voici tout de
suite les principaux titres la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité assortie d'une
peine incompressible de 30 ans eh bien
c'est la sanction requise aux assises de
la dordogne contre francis leroy cet
homme de 48 ans que l'on surnommait
l'assassin de la pleine lune
il s'agit de la peine la plus lourde
depuis l'abolition de la peine de mort à
périgueux ce soir on attend le verdict
profil bas pour les rénovateurs de
l'opposition qu'ils se réunissent demain
à lyon après les celle de simone veil
-le aux élections européennes après le
ralliement de philippe séguin à jacques
chirac hier le rôle des rénovateurs sur
l'échiquier politique reste flou et les
divisions nombreuses et puis bien sûr
bien sûr comment oublier le drame de la
chine prolongation des bourses accordées
aux étudiants chinois en france
aujourd'hui gérard les préfets ont reçu
l'ordre de renouveler titre de séjour
est permis de travail à tous ceux qui ne
veulent pas rentrer en chine un pays
toujours en proie à la répression les
autorités aux pro vo procédé à de
nouvelles arrestations sur place au delà
de la terreur au delà des arrestations
et des exécutions
l'énorme machine à écraser les
consciences est en route à l'école et à
la télévision
on étudie monsieur dengue dans le texte
de pk notre envoyé spécial jean luc
mertens alors que les condamnés à mort
présentés comme des droits communs
étaient exécutés ce matin dans le nord
de la chine
la télévision nationale diffusée ce soir
la suite du procès de six
contre-révolutionnaires à shanghai
verdict de peine de prison à vie et
quatre peines de longue durée après 20
jours de répression les autorités
chinoises paraissent pas se soucier des
réactions internationales
nous savons qu'ils sont nos amis et nos
ennemis a déclaré le premier ministre li
peng à pékin la normalisation wagon 30
nouvelles caméras de surveillance ont
été installées dans les hôtels sur les
principaux carrefours de la capitale et
au sommet des peelings cette
communication téléphonique est
enregistrée les cours de rééducation
idéologique ont commencé sur tous les
lieux
travail y compris les écoles collèges et
universités et seuls étrangers
accueillis à bras ouverts ici sont les
hommes d'affaires et les rares groupes
de touristes surtout pas les
journalistes
une vaste campagne visant les médias
occidentaux est en cours
les cameramen et les photographes sont
systématiquement contrôlés sur cassette
vidéo leurs pellicules et parfois leurs
matériels sont confisqués
la bande des vieux qui règne sur la
chine a définitivement choisi
l'isolément avec un jean luc mertens fr3
les autres temps forts de l'actualité en
france et à l'étranger voici le journal
du jour commenté par caroline flint
il sera resté 30 heures en détention
l'américain chris georges enlevé hier à
gaza a été libéré cet après-midi crise
georges s'occupe d'une association
caritative sauver les enfants dans les
territoires occupés il avait été
séquestré dans son bureau par des
palestiniens réclamant la libération de
cinq prisonniers détenus en israël
c'était le premier enlèvement ce genre
depuis le début de l'intifada fin 87
l'institut pasteur et l'institut mérieux
fusionnent regroupements d'activités
pour créer une nouvelle société but
d'être compétitifs sur le marché
international en développant de nouveaux
produits tels que vaccins et sérums
remue-ménage dans le monde du basket il
n'y a désormais plus aucune restriction
concernant le nombre de joueurs
naturalisés c'est ce que vient d'arrêter
le conseil d'état jusqu'à présent la
fédération interdisait aux classes
d'avoir plus de deux joueurs d'étrangers
ou naturalisés depuis moins de trois ans
c'est fini et certains doivent se
frotter les mains
le chiffre du jour nous est offert par
le ministère de l'économie des finances
et du budget et il est bien sûr énorme
30000 c'est le nombre de cartons
nécessaires vont déménager les papiers
et à faire des ministres est de 6000
fonctionnaires qui émigrent du louvre à
bercy à partir de l'année voilà pour ce
grand remue ménage dans la sarthe autres
remue-ménage la paroisse de bouloire je
dirais presque l'ensemble de la commune
croyants et même non croyants et bien
prend la défense de son au curé un curé
en soutane etienne célébré la messe en
latin
il faut savoir qu'à bouilloire il y a
deux communautés qui cohabitent les
traditionalistes qui sont majoritaires
et les partisans de vatican ii le
déplacement du prêt pour des raisons
administratives a provoqué un tollé chez
les traditionalistes regardez le
reportage de ben salama l'abbé jacques
pécha se curait de soixante dix ans est
à l'origine de l'effervescence à
bouloire une des quatre paroisses en
sarthe a refusé les directives du
concile vatican ii
depuis ce projet de l'évêque du mans de
le déplacer la bp chat est devenu un
symbole pour les traditionalistes de la
région je m'appartient d'aucune forme en
signant lefebvre je l'avais dit dès le
début a annoncé hier l'évêque du mans
je suis ici par la volonté d'un évêque
du mans c'était à ce moment-là le
cardinal grente et j'ai été maintenue
par les
les faits qui se sont succédé depuis
donc pour moi d'évêques ses légumes en
référence à monseigneur lefebvre mais
aussi fidélité l'évêque du mans
cette attitude de la dépêche a traduit
bien l'esprit qui anime la majorité de
ses paroissiens des paroissiens qu'il
connaît pour certains depuis 35 ans et
qu'il ne souhaite pas le voir partir
dans ces conditions une personne de son
âge jeux steam qui aurait pu le laisser
terminer sa carrière si l'on peut dire à
bouloire et puis après bon bah
évidemment les nouveaux prêtres
parce que moi pour moi la messe en
français pour moi non j'ai
personnellement mais c'est vrai qu'on a
des petits enfants et que par la suite
eh ben on sera ridicule avec notre messe
en latin ceux qui acceptent cette
évolution de l'église sont aujourd'hui
minoritaires à bouloire et doivent aller
dans la commune voisine à l'église des
loges l'abbé pêcher à lui continuera à
célébrer ses messes en latin se battre à
monségur d'avec est vrai d'une visité et
m'a annoncé que suite à la demande
populaire de deschamps de couloir je
serait maintenue comme curé de vouloir
attitude prudente du gouvernement face à
la sécheresse qui sévit en france si
besoin est des mesures de rationnement
de l'eau seront prises par les préfets
c'est ce qu'a annoncé hier le ministre
de la glisse de l'agriculture
globalement la situation ne serait pas
préoccupante reste laurence que sur le
terrain déjà en ce 23 juin et la nature
s'enflamme comme de l'étoupé c'est le
cas ce soir en haute-corse notamment
mais aussi au dessus de fréjus et puis
plus significatif encore de la
sécheresse actuelle est bien l'un tandis
qu' à la pointe de la bretagne a ravagé
depuis hier soir quelques 350 hectares
de landes sur les pentes du menez hom la
colline qui domine la presqu'île de
crozon
durant toute la journée vous le voyez
plus de deux cents sauveteurs ont
combattu les flammes qui ce matin encore
courait sur un front de plus de 800
mètres
va donc pour les incendies en bretagne
michel thoury un mot de la météo malgré
la grève de prévisionnistes de
météorologie nationale oui alors ce que
nous savons c'est plus ou même à de
belles éclaircies sur le nord et soleil
encore sur le sud voyons détail ont un
peu l'anticyclone qui affaibli ces
derniers jours à se remonter par remonte
aussi haute pression alors deux
matin ce sera pas encore terrible
terrible mais à dimanche vous aurez un
très beau dimanche sur tout le nord du
pays le nord ouest du pays
et bien c est assez gris partout
ailleurs du soleil l'est ce sera un
petit peu oui encore vous le voyez mais
cela va s'arranger au fil des heures je
vous en parlais à 19h55 les températures
matinales 10 à 14 ans de la loire 13 à
21 ans sud régionales
retour en salles de rédaction pour la
suite du 19 20 la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité assortie d'une peine
incompressible de 30 ans
c'est la sanction requise aux assises de
la dordogne contre l'assassin de la
pleine lune profil bas pour les
rénovateurs qui se réunissent demain
lyon après l'échec de simone veil aux
élections européennes après le
ralliement de philippe séguin jacques
chirac
les divisions semblent nombreuses
comment oublier le drame chinois à paris
demain on manifestera et on sera sans
doute nombreux place de la bastille en
attendant que la france et toute
l'europe s'accordent sur une sanction
officielle à l'encontre de la chine à
tous ces titres j'ajouterai je pense que
nous sommes en mesure de rejoindre tout
de suite notre studio de nice je me
renseigne excusez moi
non ce n'est pas encore possible nous
irons dans quelques minutes
un fait divers particulièrement
dramatique vient de se produire sur les
hauteurs d'antibes
ils rejoindront tout à l'heure et faire
3 nice côte d'azur tout de suite donc la
chine tout à l'heure nous entendions
s'exprimer jean-luc mertens notre envoyé
spécial à pékin qui nous disaient les
ravages et l'ampleur de la propagande
officielle chinoise nouvelle campagne de
propagande effectivement le gouvernement
de thank you ping poursuit de plus belle
la répression regardez les dernières
images qui nous sont parvenues
commentaires laurence wittner ses hommes
savent qu'ils vont mourir par fournées
étudiants ouvriers
il arrive dans ce stade rempli de
spectateurs encadré par les policiers
devant un tribunal des militaires pour
entendre les sentences la répression
s'accélère en chine les témoignages
affluent en occident comme ici aux etats
unis devant des représentants du congrès
américain est en confiance
cette prise en main ou singles en france
les excuses on s'en tape
les flics
mais soit ça a pas eu
du coup c'est de la balle dans ses
témoignages sur l'horreur du 4 juin à
pékin et dans toute la chine au chapitre
des réactions gouvernementales ce soir
c'est la belgique qui part en flèche
l annuler la visite que li peng le
premier ministre chinois est le
responsable donc de la répression devait
effectuer l'automne prochain à bruxelles
on sera sans doute lundi ou mardi au
sommet de madrid si l'europe des 12
réussi à déterminer une attitude commune
à l'égard du régime de pékin
ce qui est sûr c'est que demain à paris
à 16 heures à la bastille et bien des
associations de plus en plus nombreuses
appel à manifester et on devrait
assister à la reconstruction donc à
paris de la fameuse statue de la déesse
de la démocratie à l'identique de ce
qu'elle fut sur la place tiananmen de
pékin
jusqu'au 4 juin le gouvernement français
d'ailleurs accorde une prolongation des
bourses aux étudiants chinois titre de
séjour est permis de travail sont
renouvelés pour tous ceux qui craignent
de rentrer dans leur pays
écoutez ces témoignages recueillis cet
après-midi par marie-odile bannière en
ce moment il ya la plupart des étudiants
font ces études ont continué toujours
mais certaines risquent reçoit
recevoir des menaces la barre de chine
particulièrement de la part de
l'ambassade de chine
quel genre de menaces les menaces pour
pour sa famille en chine des pour des
personnes qui a participé que participer
vivement les mouvements à paris vous
avez de la famille en chine
oui mais la province ça risque beaucoup
moins est ce que maintenant vous avez un
peu peur même en france
personnellement j'ai beau parce que
je fais je fais lutte contre un
gouvernement fasciste
les autres titres de l'actualité des
télégrammes commenter ce soir par morad
aït habbouche
soulagement dans les territoires occupés
crise djordje après 30 heures de
détention a été libéré cet américain
directeur de l'organisation humanitaire
sauver les enfants avait été kidnappé à
gaza hier par un ou deux inconnus cet
enlèvement est le premier du genre
depuis le début du soulèvement
palestinien au zaïre une poignée de main
historique entre les deux frères ennemis
angolais le président dos santos et le
chef de la guérilla jonas savimbi une
réconciliation qui met à faire ma 14 ans
de guerres civiles
le cessez-le-feu débutera dès demain
matin le général jean rose est une
nouvelle fois montré du doigt plusieurs
milliers de polonais des militants de
l'opposition radicale ont manifesté dans
les principales villes du pays pour
réclamer le départ de l'équipe howard
genève pour protester également contre
le syndicat solidarité a accusé de
collusion avec le régime de jalouse elle
skie un syndicat qui pour la première
fois réunis ces parlementaires
branislav geremek un des proches de
walesa a été élu à leur tête en grèce
après l'échec de constantin mitsotakis
vainqueur des élections législatives le
chef d'état appelait andréas papandréou
à la rescousse pour former un
gouvernement à papandréou diminué
physiquement tout d'abord le money mais
aussi et surtout au niveau de la
représentation de son parti 125 députés
sur 300 à la chambre
une mission qui s'avère donc difficile
retour en france avec ce fait divers sur
les hauteurs d'antibes nous allons tout
de suite rejoindre jean pierre lamoure
dans nos studios de nice riches disent
certains oui alors sur les hauteurs
d'antibes ce soir une jeune fille s'est
immolé par le feu et ce faisant elle a
communiqué lincendie à toute une forêt
ce cela voilà selon un témoignage de son
ami frédéric elle aurait retrouvé une
lettre en disant je me suis suicider
avec de l'essence signée olivier arnold
résidence les pins les semboules antibes
ce serait la dernière lettre d'une jeune
fille de 17 ans qui se serait immolé
dans par le feu et qui aurait déclenché
cet incendie à 400 m d'un immense
complexe d'habitation entre valorise ces
anti blessant bouhlal est aurait confié
à frédéric qui a vu olivier à partir
avec un bidon d'essence avant de lui
confier d'autres lettres et une cassette
pour l'instant la 110 n'est pas tout à
fait maîtrisé les canadairs sont
intervenus mais aucune maison n'a été
touché par les flammes et le corps de
livia serait toujours au centre du
sinistre le seul témoin frédéric et peu
entendu ans
ce moment par le commissaire huguenin
mais toujours selon le témoignage de
cette jeune fille frédérique donc cette
olivia se serait immolé dans ce petit
bois à 400 mètres des habitations des
symboles merci jean pierre lamoure voici
donc ce que l'on pouvait dire à chaud ce
soir sur ce drame terrible de la mort
l'immolation par le feu d'une jeune
fille de 17 ans au-dessus d'antibes
laurent réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité assortie d'une peine
incompressible de 30 ans c'est ce qu'a
requis l'avocat général a contre la ccin
de la pleine lune devant les assises de
la dordogne et ce matin francis leroy 48
ans est il est vrai un récidiviste et
c'est bien pourquoi la peine maximale
prévue par la loi depuis l'abolition de
la peine de mort a été requise contre
lui
à périgueux où on attend ce soir donc le
verdict nous rejoignons notre confrère
de fr3 aquitaine
je ne lui reconnaît aucune circonstance
atténuante pour moi c'est un chacal
symbole mythologique de la mort il faut
casser cet enchaînement de crimes de
sang et de larmes versées gérard aldigé
l'avocat général a prononcé ce matin un
réquisitoire implacable qui a expulsé
définitivement la lune du prétoire
il ne faut pas confondre pathologie
mentale et traits de caractère le roi
est responsable de ses actes
c'est encore l'avocat général c'est un
assassin force est donc de constater que
la réadaptation doit faire place ici à
la neutralisation
en conséquence le représentant de la
société a réclamé la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité assortie d'une
peine de sûreté incompressible de 30 ans
une peine jamais encore prononcé depuis
son vote en septembre 86 abasourdi la
défense laisser tomber la lune dans le
caniveau
tout en notant ce moment au passage
qu'il est utile de poser quelques fois à
la justice des questions 9
et si un jour il y avait un traitement
pour le roi demandé m cannon 30 ans
c'est l'équivalent de la peine de mort
s'exclame et pierre blazy
comme si le roi était longue rue ou
pettiaux alors même que la preuve de
l'homicide volontaire n'est pas apportée
par l'accusation
c'est important ici car s'il
homicide involontaire ses 15 ans et non
trente ans vous êtes des juges et non
des victimes dit encore avec force
pierre blazy aux jurés pour tenter
d'exorciser leur peur des jurés qu'ils
vont répondre tout à l'heure à pas moins
de 70 questions chacun ce sera long et
nous n'attendons pas ici l'énoncé du
verdict avant le début de la nuit
peut-être donc ce verdict dans soir 3
politique française depuis dimanche soir
et les résultats des élections
européennes il n'est plus question que
de rénovation dans les états-majors de
l'opposition dans toute cette frénésie
que deviennent ceux qui au printemps
jeune et peu nombreux avaient les
premiers brandit le concept de
rénovation eh bien demain c'est à lyon
que ces cadets se sont donnés rendez
vous rendez vous important demain avec
leurs conventions les rénovateurs
devront mettre un terme à leur
éventuelle division déterminer aussi une
action pour les mois à venir
charles millon un des chefs de file du
mouvement de la rénovation était
l'invité de nos confrères à fr3 y ont
écouté le le mouvement n'a jamais été
aussi puissant pondent raison en simple
c'est que dès le début de son action les
rénovateurs ont dit deux choses nous
voulons l'union par la rénovation ou
pour la rénovation
l'union a été plébiscité dimanche
dernier puisque les français ont dit
très clairement nous souhaitons l'union
mais les français ont en même temps dit
mais la rénovation n'ayant pas eu lieu
pour un certain nombre nous
désintéressons du débat politique et
cette semaine qu est ce que vous avez vu
vous avez vu valéry giscard d'estaing a
annoncé qu'il était favorable à une
rénovation de l'opposition il propose la
fusion du rpr de l'udf
vous avez vu jacques chirac qui a
proposé à son propre parti une
rénovation était acquis à refuser la
vous avez vu françois léotard qui a
exposé la nécessité impérieuse qu'il y
avait des navets l'opposition le
mouvement des rénovateurs n'a jamais été
aussi puissant et continuera donc son
action pour que les paroles deviennent
des actes donc d'après vous les plus
grands rénovateurs du jour sont valéry
giscard d'estaing et jacques chirac et
françois lyotard si je vous ai suivi là
c'est pour les plus grands et les plus
récents voilà ce que disait fond
monsieur millions il ya un instant donc
à notre confrère jean pierre bennechet
sur le plateau de fr3 lyon dans le camp
d'en face au parti socialiste et bien on
commence aussi à bouger dans l'optique
d'un congrès
devraient être réunis en février ou en
mars 90 et bien pierre mauroy le premier
secrétaire du ps
adresse ce soir une lettre aux militants
dans laquelle il souhaite je cite que
soit brisée ce qu'il appelle les
courants de clientèle à l'intérieur du
parti
le sport devient le carrefour de toutes
les tensions conflit financier on le
savait déjà mais débat éthique c'est
plus nouveau en basketball la fédération
avait décidé qu'un joueur naturalisé ne
devenait vraiment joueurs français qu'au
bout de trois ans eh bien le conseil
d'état ce soir donne tort à la
fédération française de basket le
règlement de la fédération est qualifiée
d'illégale pas question donc de limiter
le nombre de joueurs naturalisés les
explications tout de suite avec
jean-philippe bien jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et selon un article du règlement de la
fédération de basket
l'effectif d'une équipe ne pouvait
compter que deux joueurs non
sélectionnable en équipe de france deux
joueurs étrangers naturalisés depuis
moins de trois ans c'est cet article que
le conseil d'état juge maintenant
illégales les contraires à l'article 80
du code de la nationalité qui prévoit
que chaque individu doit bénéficie le
jour où ils acquièrent la nationalité
française de tous les droits attachés à
cette qualité
fini donc la limitation et de la saison
90-91 un président de club pourrait très
bien aligné cinq américains sur le
parquet en même temps à savoir de
véritables étrangers et trois naturalisé
emporter ainsi le championnat mais faire
ensuite bien pâle figure en compétition
internationale où seul un naturalisé est
admis la fédération qui doit se plier à
la décision du conseil d'état se rend
bien compte du danger et devrait
rapidement réagir pour éviter ce genre
d'excès mais cet arrêt du conseil d'état
peut quand même avoir d'importantes
conséquences pour tout le sport
hexagonal
cette décision pourrait faire
jurisprudence dans votre discipline
comme le hockey sur glace ou le handball
là aussi une pléiade de naturaliser
pourraient venir grossir les rangs de
plusieurs clubs bas feront au passage
les principes d'équité sportive
historique le ministère des finances
quitte le louvre havre après plus d'un
siècle de présence
un sacré travail 30000 cartons ont été
déménagées serra et le ministre d'état
pierre bérégovoy à la tête de quelques
6000 fonctionnaires et bien a fait ses
bagages il les a bouclé ce matin le
reportage le faire 3 ile de france passe
sans les ministres des finances de la
france auront désormais vue sur la seine
en s'installant provisoirement à partir
de lundi dans ce bureau pierre bérégovoy
rompt avec une tradition vieille de
plusieurs siècles les travaux à bercy ne
sont pas complètement terminés
le ministre devra attendre la fin de
l'année pour occuper son bureau
définitif et son appartement un duplex
de 180 m² au sol mais à bercy il n'y
aura pas que des ministres bérégovoy et
ses collègues du budget du commerce
extérieur et de la consommation
il y aura aussi les 6000 fonctionnaires
de la plus grosse administration
centrale du pays
6000 fonctionnaires pour cinq bâtiments
260 mille mètres carrés de surface et 25
km de couloirs des chiffres
impressionnants qui s'explique par la
volonté de regrouper des services venue
de 40 endroits différents dans paris au
rang des innovations les plus
spectaculaires la mise en place d'un
très électronique qui acheminera le
courrier dans tous les bureaux les
agents évidemment trouveront dans ces
bâtiments des conditions qu'il n'avait
pas bien sûr au louvre il trouve par
exemple des systèmes de traitement
informatisé nous avons complètement
câblée ce bâtiment ce qui en fait l'un
des premiers bâtiments intelligents
réalisé en france
faut-il dire pour autant que le louvre
était un bâtiment bête
les derniers des agents ou encore le
week-end pour transporter le milieu
carton restant quant aux contribuables
il peut toujours espérer que sa feuille
d'impôts s'est égaré dans le plus grand
déménagement jamais réalisée en france
on peut toujours rêver et oui on peut
toujours rêver
mystère autour de la pollution qui
touche aujourd'hui deux villages de l'un
deux villages qui ont en commun depuis
hier d'être ravitaillés en eau potable
par camions citernes
un forage pétrolier pourrait avoir percé
la nappe phréatique c'est en tout cas
l'explication la plus plausible
reportage et faire trois lions dans un
petit instant à seulement un petit
problème technique oui
oui mais plus tout laurent sont
identiques ne s'agit pas d' oui on va
d'abord par les gérard du baccalauréat
en corse à ajaccio notamment où il ya eu
quelques fraudes
alors que près de 500 mille jeunes
français en termine des épreuves du
baccalauréat et bien on reparle comme
chaque année de fraude et de fuite et
même quelquefois de commerce de sujets
c'est le cas c'est l' enquête s'est
ouverte aujourd'hui en corse à propos de
sujets de philosophie et d'histoire
géographie
la nouvelle est donc officielle depuis
cet après midi 14 heures les épreuves
d'histoire et géographie comptant pour
le baccalauréat 89 sont purement et
simplement annulée pour toute la région
corse
une décision sans précédent sur l'île
décrétée par le rectorat d'académie
après qu'une association de professeurs
d'histoire-géographie d'ajaccio est
apporté la preuve que des sujets
circulait bien sous le manteau 24 heures
avant l'épreuve suite à des rumeurs de
plus en plus persistantes le rectorat
avait pourtant commandité une enquête
administrative
le 9 juin dernier au lendemain des
premières épreuves consacré à la
philosophie sans résultat apparent mais
cette fois devant le fait accompli on
s'étonne et on se défend une seule
personne au rectorat a mis ce sujet dans
les enveloppes à destination des centres
d'examen ces ombres portées cachetées de
cire et ont été ouvertes en présence des
élèves avec signature des surveillants
de sa imprimé sur le continent les
milliers d'intituler sont arrivés le 3
juin dernier sur l'île soit quatre jours
avant le début de l'examen provenant des
académies d'aix pour
l'histoire-géographie nice pour les
mathématiques et marseille pour les
autres matières les sujets ont été par
la suite qu'on voyait par le directeur
des examens d'ajaccio en personne avant
de dormir quelques heures
au fond d'une chambre forte de square le
mystère reste donc entier et la tâche
des enquêteurs s'annonce très difficile
en attendant ce sont plus de 1500
potache ils seront condamnés dès lundi
art plancher sur un sujet de secours
la preuve est faite qu'il a eu des
fuites donc entre le continent et la
corse autre fuite
mystère en tous les cas sur
l'alimentation en eau potable de deux
communes du département de l'ain nous
avons failli vous lancer ce sujet tout à
l'heure le voici le voilà les fuites
seraient peut-être des fuites de pétrole
dans la nappe phréatique
oualalou qui a commencé a coulé des
robinets doute ria et de vieux 19 dans
la la source de la moule qui
approvisionne ces deux petites communes
s'est mystérieusement transformé à la
place de l'eau de la montagne c'est une
espèce de laine minérale qui coule
de mémoire d'homme on n'a jamais lu ce
phénomène d'autre part le deuxième point
c'est la baisse du débit qui sait le
volume d'eau a baissé de façon
inquiétante
les maires et les habitants des deux
communes sont perplexes mais il se doute
de quelque chose le groupe esso à
quelques kilomètres des deux villages a
entrepris un forages prometteurs de
prospection pétrolière et apparemment ce
forage a fait littéralement éclater la
nappe phréatique et à polluer la source
à plus de mille mètres de profondeur
du coup les habitants n'ont plus d'eau
et s'approvisionne en camion citerne
point de vue coût non on peut produire
que l'eau et la mauvais goût mais enfin
elle était répugnante au point deux
aspects c'est à dire qu'elles étaient
troublants choses donc on pourrait
produire on la consomme is est out ria
vieux 19
on s'inquiète on sait que si la source
est vraiment polluée il faudra payer une
facture énorme pour faire venir de l'au
delà de la montagne et sopera peut-être
en attendant couler l'eau claire un beau
jour les habitants espèrent bien voir
transformer ce mauvais débit de lait emb
haut débit d'eau d'autres informations
en provenance des 25 stations régionales
de la 3 commentaires jérôme cathala
90 emplois supprimés à l'usiné rayon
d'annemasse en haute-savoie raisons
essentielles la restructuration du
groupe tapie à qui appartient terraillon
tapis en effet racheter son concurrent
principal britannique
henson et va installer outre manche
l'ensemble de son activité de pesage
mécanique terraillon devrait devenir
numéro un mondial dans ce domaine
un pâle andrier de l'île d'elbe
arraisonné par la vedette des affaires
maritimes de bastia le bateau italien
pêcher dans les eaux corps est sûre en
flagrante violation des règlements
internationaux les déchets record se
sont actuellement particulièrement
vigilant à quelques années du marché
unique de 93
les cheminots de la région sncf de
chambéry ont voté la poursuite de leur
mouvement de grève jusqu'à demain
ils ont également maintenu leurs
barrages sur les voies de la gare de
chambéry
cette grève concerne les départements de
l'ain de l'isère de la haute savoie et
de la savoie
les cheminots réclament des
augmentations de salaires et la fin des
suppressions de postes dans le secteur
attentes
on menace plane sur montpellier le vieux
ce site naturel en bordure du causse
noir
la société d'exploitation a commencé à
faire creuser une route sur laquelle un
petit train touristique devraient
circuler
mais les verts de l'aveyron protestent
car montpellier le vieux est un site
classé
puis l'un des plus jolis sites naturels
que compte la france
un peu de nostalgie à présent les plus
anciens se rappellent juan manuel fangio
place du volant et bien aujourd'hui sur
maserati sur sa maserati
il était de retour sur le circuit de
montlhéry la nostalgie c'est de nous
faire des affaires 3 ile de france
traditionnel rendez-vous de l'âge d'or
automobile demain et dimanche à
montlhéry 3000 voitures anciennes
exposées 300 pilotes en course avec en
vedette phil hill carroll shelby henri
grenet et pour leurs 75 ans d'existence
les célèbres maserati 4 cl 250 f 450 s
reine des circuits d'hier la firme de
modène est le symbole même de la course
illustrée par les victoires des nues
volaris ascari fangio et ancelin à leurs
côtés les ferrari amilcar alfa romeo db
et autres jaguar pour un spectacle rétro
d'où l'émotion n'est pas absente 300
coureurs voudront démontrer au public
que le grand prix de l'âge d'or est bien
le troisième événement auto après les 24
heures et le grand prix de f1 ce
rassemblement de véhicules d'époque
comptant pour le championnat d'europe
retrace l'histoire du sport automobile
ce soir sur la chaîne eh bien d'abord le
masque série à 20h35 21h35 n'oubliez pas
thalassa et 22h30 soir 3 présenté par
maguy giesbert le retour de michael
gilbert après quelques jours de vacances
on se retrouve demain samedi merci
bonsoir ensuite la météo de michel noël
il dit